[Music]
Britain has some of the finest
restaurants in the world we were a conry
underdog for years but now we're at the
top of our game so who's the very best I
asked you where you love to eat out and
you sent me over 12,000 nominations for
this competition but they can only be
one winner how do I find them by
choosing my two favorites every week and
testing them to the absolute Breaking
Point who will crack under the
incredible pressure and who will come sh
Shing
[Music]
through over the last 6 months my team
and I have been checking out your best
loved restaurants from thousands of
nominations tonight the competition
continues with another of your top Cy
favorites
Chinese Chinese food is one of the great
Cuisines of the world top Chinese chefs
you techniques and flavor combinations
that you won't find in any other
Cuisine there's a Chinese restaurant on
nearly every High Street and there's an
incredible range from small family run
outfits the mission star fine dining
pleas C noodles please thank you D we
tend to think of Chinese food has been
all about chow and special fried rice
but great Chinese restaurants serve food
that's as sophisticated and complex as
anything you'll find in a Posh fench
Restaurant I've chosen two fantastic
restaurants to battle it out for a place
in the semi-finals tonight from Mayfair
in London it's the crazy Cy Genius of
Kai no my style of C is the new modern
Chinese as a chef we need to P from our
heart versus the best of the Northwest
blackburns you and you a brilliant
family run
restaurant let the food do the talking
earliest memory of food was just cooking
with my father he said oh you can't
reach the cookers so stand on these four
cases to live yourself up I can only
choose one Chinese restaurant to go
through the semi-final so they must
prove to me beyond all doubt that they
are the most worthy contender
I'm going to subject both restaurants to
three challenging tests starting with a
coach load of 30 guests all arriving and
ordering at the same time every
restaurant's worst
nightmare first they'll SAS a into
Mayfair to sample the avangard Delights
on offer at Michigan star Kai where is
he Chef nice to you you look like you
just come with a Chinese boy band look
at that hair incredible super star I
know you are a
superstar Kai's kitchen is led by Alex
the demanding head
chef he's a perfectionist who runs his
kitchen with a rod of iron to ensure his
sophisticated dishes are spot on every
time how many time I'm told you f man
Alex H's skills in some of Asia's top
festar hotels before being poached by
Kai's ambitious owner burnard the
intention was to change people's
perceptions about Chinese restaurants
they're trying to reinvent Chinese
cuisine and they put a 21st century
Twist on it amongst Kai's bold and
unusual dishes is a unique liquid
version of a lamb shank that does not
look like a lamb shank in there so is it
supposed to be like a lamb shank soup or
yes right yes it's it's one of those
dishes which catches people out by
surprise so a lot of people absolutely
love it and some people don't like it
I've just never had a lamb shank like
that before no no absolutely not um if
you're going to sell that today
obviously on the menu make sure the
customers understand what it is before
yes I don't want them disappointed they
taste delicious it's just a really
strange way of executing it I love these
guys they are very very creative and
this food is out there and I just hope
that my diners get it and love the exper
experience Kai will need to be on top of
their game to survive My ultimate
pressure
test two hours two courses yeah I'm
going to be over everything I'll be in
the kitchen I'll be in the dining room
and I'll be watching and listening to
everything so make sure that you give my
diners an experience never to forget
normally bookings are staggered to take
the pressure off the kitchen but not
tonight my 30 diners will push Kai to
the edge and give them a chance to
shine on Alex's ultra mod menu tonight
is a choice of three starters Wasabi
prawns with mango and basil seeds
steamed Scarlets with ginger and spring
onions and Ka on ususual take on a lamb
starter how you free lamb
Shack can't give you a whole lamb sh you
eat else with such radical dishes my
guests will need a clear explanation
when they order got the flavor of lamb
shine but it actually comes as a soup
get ready to
go the first orders hit the kitchen and
it sounds like je Alex is launching a
fullscale military
assault okay Al yeah okay yeah and uh
what's the table for table five
for
go do you have any uh new a friend I got
a
headache why is everyone
shouting why is every
shouting why is everybody shouting no no
because the the order I need to
coordinate just moments into service and
it's clear that Kai's unusual first
course isn't going down well with my
diners no want they want
to the description of it wasn't quite
what I expected okay that should have
been explained year already I apologize
for that so I'd like possible to change
this for the scop
dish like the the L Shang was too wet I
didn't explain it was a wet dish like a
soup scar but they want to um change it
for the scolar so I've ordered on
table
five one of my diners just complained
about the lam shank gloopy soupy and
know they expected sadly exactly what I
predicted
liquid lamb shank may be a step too far
for my guess so I hope Alex's amazingly
sophisticated main courses are going to
impress he's working his ass off to make
soy and honey marinated lamb spiced with
chilies and an extravagant Lobster dish
scented with crisp Curry leaves and
cooked with lemon chili and
shalots
and now front of house is getting in a
muddle didn't know where to start yours
hadn't come that is our starter with the
main course nothing seems to be coming
out together we can't keep a table
hanging for 7 minutes without anything
else arriving on a day like today that's
what I'm trying to say okay okay well
not it thank you take there go s my
let's do the new old everything for you
okay
[__] who called away the main call if
they haven't finished the
starters no they finished it but they
wanted another St so you can't send a
starter and then 10 seconds later send
the main course can you I get so my
question originally was who called away
the main courses I did
right g g just put here I will handle
it Alex is it always this crazy there
busy uh it's a very chaotic service and
uh yeah one shouting fine but 15 sh at
the same time
it's such a mess that one Diner's dish
the lamb has been missed altogether I'm
hoping it's going to arrive Rec soon
because I'm I'm very very hungry at the
moment Al my lamp I need one lamp please
one L he's coming he's coming he's
coming
okay sh okay for a Michin Star
Restaurant this is unforgivable even
worse Bernard the owner is busy serving
up excuses for he Stars cock-ups
normally a meal here everything is in
the middle of the table so everybody's
sharing it's just unusually today um
we've had to serve everything
individually I don't know why you why
you doing that the share a startups fine
but the order remain cause I think that
customer deserves it the fact that he
took the order down incorrectly it's not
the customer's fault AB but we shouldn't
be telling them that I'd rather you just
sort of hand in the air deal with it and
move on okay my
apologies one
table once the food arrives most of my
diners are blown away by Alex his
amazing dishes it is fantastic the the
the Lamb's tender just wonderful think I
had Lobster and it was absolutely
fantastic I've never had Lobster that's
been fried before um and it was a really
nice contrast as well as having the
strawberries and the grapes in there the
lobster was lovely very uh subtle
flavors of garlic and chili but yeah
amazing end of
service and time to tell Kai what I
thought the customers are did get the
food on time loved the food it's quirky
and it's very striking when it hits all
those notes but we have to remember that
when customers com here for the first
time you got to hold their hand every
step of the way that's where we got to
work on you just got to keep working
keep working keep working making a
little bit better every single time
absolutely but I know you can go further
because you've done it with the food and
you can do it with the service as well
hit all those notes there put them
together bang you have an amazing
restaurant thank you next come on Victor
what the [__] are you doing what is that
Kai's Northern competitors you and you
struggle as the war of the walks heats
up a lot on your shoulders right now and
that standard has to be met by you
today I'm scouring the country in a
quest to find my very best restaurant my
coach load of 30 diners is about to hit
the second Chinese restaurant battling
for a place in the semi-finals of my
Nationwide competition it's family run
you and you in Blackburn so many of you
nominated them you and you had to go
into my top two
[Music]
Chinese it's got that that energy that
Vibe and this family run run with great
Passion you can feel that because they
care about every little
detail family is the most important part
of this restaurant I think personally it
makes this restaurant what it is you
know it it that's the heart and soul of
the restaurant it's not just a
livelihood it's more than that it's it's
a definite passion dad Charlie started
out with a chippy over 30 years ago
before opening his first restaurant in
1989 he's 65 it's still flames in him
you know he's like he's quicker than me
there's a saying um the older the ginger
the hotter it gets now all three of his
children work in the business good work
good work what makes this restaurant
Stand Out is that Charlie and his head
chef son Victor Source the very best
local
ingredients the scolars are massive all
right there this morning that beautiful
thank
you you and you will have just 2 hours
to serve all 30 of my diners a perfect
meal I'm excited I'm ready tonight's
dishes include handd salt and pepper
scallops f it steak with hoison and
chili bean sauce and a luxurious stir
fried DOA
Sal absolutely delicious it's cook
beautifully and for me what that dish
needs is just a touch more seasoning
yeah thank you good thank you
side order with you m c sir my diners
look excited by what's on offer but I
wish the front of house team would make
a point of telling them how fantastic
the raw ingredients are like the salt
and pepper scallops with asparagus and
mushrooms for all they know the sculps
could have come from the supermarket
it's Victor and Charlie's chance to show
me they can handle this challenge let
the food do the
talking once that turbo walk is fired up
dishy start flying out the door amazing
yeah well that's quick it's just over 2
minutes from the first order coming in
for food to leave the
kitchen Victor's brother and sister are
joined front of house by at least eight
other waiting staff who seem to do a lot
of waiting seems to be a lot of people
just Milling about and not really paying
the attention to the
table are we having a beauty pageant in
here look at these waitresses in here
Blackburn's Next Top
[Music]
Model
sex it's complete Overkill and half the
time they don't even know where to put
themselves my main concern is the way
the kitchen is
working Victor the head chef picks the
ingredients another Chef adds the
sauce then it's Dad Charlie who does all
the
cooking 65 years of age he's there
pounding every dish just cooking cooking
cooking and not even coming up
a the old man's going one doing all the
work don't you feel
guilty that's the way he wants to do it
that's how he wants to do it Charlie huh
you want some help yeah yeah yeah in the
kitchen has a little bit weird for me
the only one doing any work is your dad
he's control control is he a control
fruit for yeah is he
yeah needs to let go a little bit he
still thinks he's going to do one day a
week at 90 seriously seriously yeah how
day you having
orders have already backed up by the
time head chef Victor steps into help
with the
cooking there's something quite unique
about seeing a father and son on the
stove together you know that when
they're not arguing they're not arguing
too busy to
[Music]
argue although dishes are now getting
out there's a problem a bit of soy sauce
bit of soy sauce yeah I'll sort it for
you no problem no one's tasting anything
which is quite normal for the way they
work as a Chinese Kitchen but the young
guys now starting to cook and also
Victor's cooking as well now so you got
the same dish be cooked by three
different individuals so that's how
things started becom inconsistent I
can't believe that Charlie and Victor
are letting down their delicious and
unique ingredients through lack of
seasoning they taste a little bit Bland
yeah just not as tasty what I've had
them before and you know I would just
expected to two different tables and one
table enjoyed the scolars one felt they
were a little bit Bland so just make
sure if somebody's going to cook it they
got to taste it as well if it needs a
touch more salt okay Charlie thank you
thank you it's not just the scallops
they're also under seasoning their most
expensive dish three plates of the 30
ahead do Soul have been sent back do me
a favor do me another do Sal what's
wrong do Sal is under
seasoned is it tasted
it it definitely needs more salt tast
Andy a bit more TI at the beginning of
service I mentioned that over Soul yeah
fish tastes delicious but it's
underseasoned and three times tonight
you it's come back Bland you got to you
got to do it justice Charlie's having to
redo the soul it's an expensive dish to
get wrong so many times Charlie
Chase watch him
through when they hit their stride you
and 's food is extraordinary what you
have I had scops to start with scops how
are they really nice and the May the
filet Ste was absolutely delicious yeah
now that you family need to hear what I
thought of tonight's
service this is a first for me I've
never come across a Chinese restaurant
that has such unique ingredients and so
if you are going to Helen Back To Source
those ingredients shout about it I could
cry on the back of the DOA Soul because
I said to you when you cooked it from me
me earlier it needed more seasoning and
it came back three times tonight taste
it do it
jce yeah you're the
chef and your father's the Sue chef and
tonight it looked like you were the
apprentice and your father was the chef
and grab the rins and let him sit behind
you well done thank you slow down
now all right Slow Down slow
if they home in on those small little
details with the final seasoning across
those dishes and you've got something
pretty
[Music]
phenomenal Kai and you and you have
cooked their hearts out but both had
their failings and things are about to
get a whole lot tougher the coast trip
really showed me what these Chinese
competitors are made of and now I've
called both of them to a meeting with me
to find out how they restaurants run
when I'm not breathing down their necks
I've been spying on them and they have
no idea if you want to know how a
restaurant treats an ordinary customer
on an ordinary day send in a secret
Diner that's exactly what I do they
should get amazing food and an excellent
service nothing less is good
[Music]
enough Sarah dur and Robertson has
worked with me and other top chefs to
create and perfect thousands of
dishes is there anywhere you can turn
the noise down a
bit through critic Simon Davis is one of
the best in the business and has judged
food and service at thousands of
restaurants I'm allergic to
those I can't eat sultanas it's one
thing serving easy to please customers
but how will my competitors perform when
my undercover diners are deliberately
difficult and
demanding first up is kayenne Mayfair in
their first test my customers didn't get
a proper steer on Alex's ambitious menu
has owner burnard improved things since
my last
visit that was a big test unknown to all
of you you've been tested twice after I
left Kai I sent in my secret
Diner and I need you to watch
[Music]
this yes at 1:00 1:00
yes for starters I've ordered wasab
porns and soft sh crab but I'm going to
change my order once I've seen that he's
put it through and I'm going to order
the lamb shank sorry can I change my
order started from I'd like the um lamb
shank L pleas yes thank
you PR J mango okay hi sorry I asked to
swap for the lamb shank oh swap oh was
additional order you want to cancel this
yeah okay that's fine that's fine no
thank you
so the kitchens ended up cooking an
extra dish because the waiter never said
that it was an exchange that's why he
didn't come and ask seems to be a bit of
a lack of communication between some of
the frontal house staff in the kitchen
what goes through your mind when you see
that there Bernard uh I think part of
the reason why we made a mistake is
because it's not unusual for somebody to
have three starters between two
people oh my goodness in a martini glass
that's not what I was
expecting wow
you enjoy it thank
you did I read the menu right that bears
no resemblance to the dish that I was
reading about I'm really sorry I just I
can't believe that that's what I ordered
is that the
L very weird could I have the soft shell
crab instead sof crab yeah thank you it
wasn't clear from the menu at all that
that's what that dish comes like
why are we serving lamb shank in a
martini glass that's
hot it just seems so strange and such a
bizarre thing to do uh it's a f fancy
stter fancy
starter
Jesus thank
you thanks I thought that was supposed
to be have the many flaming table side I
thought the pork was supposed to arrive
flaming at the you see flaming no oh was
it there I missed
it so there's a great dramatic dish on
the menu that has a reason to be great
and dramatic and they do it at the
customer's back I can't see it my guest
can't see it completely pointless I said
where did that happen sorry just behind
you what's the point of that the the
issue we have with the Chinese St wine
flaming it's that very often the Flames
are quite hard to see no one can see the
[__] flame cuz it doesn't give off a
lot of flame it's a little bit of fun
it's a bit of Showmanship I don't see
anything wrong with that there's a
consistent strand through here that
you're trying to be clever with the
martini glass the lamb shank and now
you're fling something that has got
nothing to do with
flavor don't damage what you got by
trying to be too
clever first time to it is yeah I'm very
sorry that that's
not how things run so um take care of
your that's right oh no seriously not we
but that's extraordinarily kind I mean
the dishes have been delicious that's
really kind thank
you now that's somebody who clearly
Prides himself on the service they feel
they ought to offer and on the food they
want to hit the table it has to be
perfect on they're not happy and he's
really not
happy okay um brilliantly handled at the
end offering the whole thing on the
[Music]
house I think the the emotion I feel
right now is more determination than
disappointment you've got to get your
head down and make things better I hope
we can uh win
it next the team from blackburns you and
you face the wrath of my secret Diner I
really would like to have a drink
actually I get
James tonight two fantastic restaurants
are battling out to become my best
Chinese and win a place in the
semi-finals of my Nationwide restaurant
competition [__] H time for you and you
to find out how they measured up when I
sent in my secret
spy unknown to all four of you you've
actually been tested twice
I sent
in my secret Diner and this is what he
saw so here we are you and you I told
the you family to focus on detail and to
properly season the stunning ingredients
they source and I want to see them use
the waiting sta wisely so they're not
just hanging around I booked at a table
got I got table name of Duncan for two
people at
[Music]
8:00 would have hoped you have been off
for the drink by now having been here
for five minutes I know that busy but
there's quite a lot of Staff as well
can't see who's managing the place it
feels a bit
frantic I really would like to have a
drink actually I get rather annoyed can
we want some drinks have to call over
the waiters to get a drink given that to
my right there's four waiters and
waitresses and they've all got their
backs to us and I'm sure they're busy
it's a busy night
but we need
to 10 minutes for a drink is that normal
they wait 10 15 minutes no it's not but
that wasn't a normal Friday night cuz
one of the kitchen hands was off Hill
yeah so I had to go in and help these
guys that's why I Disappeared for so
long what you need to do is pay money
for better staff and less of them that
are more reliable the B our starters
really quickly which was admirable but
the problem is there's now a huge gap
between starters main quarters they
should bring the starters out a b a
little bit later then there would be
such a glaring
Gap what they should be doing now is
coming up to us and just having a quiet
word say I'm very sorry blah blah blah
and you know what that would completely
dilute the
situation completely ignored completely
ignored it becomes an insult where they
become offended like he said diffuse
it that's
okay okay thank you this DOA saw which
sugar snap be looks actually rather
rather
Bland um and the fish
itself it's pretty nondescript hi there
I just this over so it doesn't really
taste much it needs some much more
seasoning yeah when you've got customers
that are sat waiting over half an hour
for food it's got to be perfect that was
dealt with quite well so I'm going to
send this back again to change the dish
I still don't like it I'm afraid right
I'll change it to something else for you
you mind not I'm so sorry after all that
effort I've complained a hell of a lot
in restaurants but that is the best I've
almost ever seen it dealt with 10 out of
10 for dealing with a very very tricky
customer brilliantly handled and he's
fussy beautifully
done oh I really really really really
like
that the strawberry s so it's worth a
trip alone
seriously I've never
heard such an amazing compliment to
Chinese
desserts fantastic really good as a
dining experience it had a quite a
sluggish start but it's just accelerated
and I've now reached a crescendo where I
think this is one of the one of the best
Chinese restaurants I've been to in many
years what a strong finish and he left
on a
high we've got this far now we just
really want to I'm ready to explode I'm
ready to win this competition I'm going
to take this and hope get to the end of
this competition you know my two best
Chinese restaurants have one final
chance to really deliver in my
competition I'm taking them out of their
comfort zones and into the kitchen of my
own Michelin St
restaurant I've asked each Chef to
create one one amazing dish for 20
guests the test here today is about
quality and consistency every single
plate they produce must be
perfect their performance will win one
of them a place in the semi-finals the
other will be eliminated from the
competition the pressure will either
make or break
them see the them on the menu that G's
three star Mitchell in restaurant
yeah yeah just just don't believe
want to win this we [__] our
out oh me and M
were definitely try our best to make the
the diner happy
yes this is an amazing battle about to
take place now because we've got two
completely contrasting restaurants I
want the quality to stand out create
something magical the sad news is
there's only one of you going through to
the
semi-final make sure it's you good luck
to both of you thank
you they must create their dish using
the finest quality beef as their main
ingredient and I'm expecting great
things from both
teams it's not just me they have to
impress some highly distinguished guests
will also judge both restaurants dishes
including Daya Shong a world Authority
on Chinese cuisine and respected
businesswoman May Sim Li OB I've also
invited each restaurant's front of house
[Music]
team for the chefs there is nowhere to
hide I'm expecting culinary
Perfection okay on order four covers
Table Six Kai Four beef and Ginger okay
uh yes chef would be great yes chef
thank you is it easier if I share like
that is that will that will that make it
any easier no tell me no is it would you
is it easier okay good no just in
case at Kai Alex is a gifted and
passionate Mastermind elevating modern
Chinese food to new
heights Alex and Wing his suf hope to
enchant my guest with a creation you'd
never find on a High Street Chinese
menu they're making be sirloin with
ginger and spring onion pesto served
with broccolini bamboo stalks and
pumpkin it's accompanied by spiced rice
and a soy reduction how you going to
cook the beef I pencil y then I kind to
the rectangular then I finish in the
around one and a half minute it's so
nice to see my kitchen and how nice is
that we've been here 5 minutes you
haven't shouted okay very good thank you
excellent on order you and you two cover
away table three please two stunning
wagu beef yes
chef
yes sir thanks Charlie in contrast you
andu is going for more classic dish
walked Kobe beef with sweet soy sauce
lime garlic and ginger Kobe beef is an
amazingly tender cut of meat but the
Magic in this dish lies with the
flavoring that's what we've always done
that time keeping things simple using
fresh really good ingredients you know
I've been waiting to see if Victor the
head chef can live up to the title and
take control from his
father
Victor I want you tasting today every
[__] thing you put on that plate I
want to see you taste I need to see you
taste yeah a lot on your shoulders right
now and that standard has to be met by
you today yeah sure Victor has the
pressure of the competition and the
desire to impress his dad resting on his
shoulders he needs to stay calm and in
control but for my first table of four
Victor dishes up just one plate that's
the first speed yes so just missing two
more sh sorry missing what just missing
three more on there sh so is that three
in there yeah how long's that going to
take 3 minutes just finish no how long
is it going to take 4 minutes Che 4
minutes well that's going to be [__] by
4 minutes what do you want me to do
serve that or you going to do four fresh
portions again there serve that
sh
[Music]
come on Victor I know you can do better
than this I can't just serve one portion
what do you want me to do do you want to
take it back I can't just serve one 2
minutes and have this one up here
service please go with that please yeah
is there any rice is that the no R is
coming about to say one come on guys
listen just stop come here two seconds
what the [__] are you doing what is that
this is your moment do you understand
this is your standards so get that back
in there and split it between four
playes come on guys I know you can do
better than this but if you talk to each
other the rice comes at the same
time [__] hell
guys bad start by you and you I mean
completely disorientated no teamwork and
they're far than son for God's sake
today they look like two strangers in a
kitchen come here two seconds you this
is not a [__] rehearsal do you
understand I can't just send out one
portion yes I've got dining room full of
guests out there yes listen to me yes
and more importantly slow down and come
to the hot plate together okay come on
that's
go on the other side of the kitchen Alex
is also feeling the pressure Kai two
portions away Alex two please stand by
the plate look at me look at me four
more beef that's it thank you after now
is two bees yes CH thank
you [__] hell two trays in the hot
plate please Alex isn't communicating
with me or is suf Wing [__] hell come
on guys guys and this complex dish needs
perfect coordination Alex look at me if
we can get a little bit organized yeah
so the beef doesn't hang around too long
on the hot plate yeah it's got to go it
can't sit here too long got to work
together a little bit more yes sure yeah
so you're putting it on it's taking
about four or 5 minutes but it's got to
go we can't keep it back too long yeah
otherwise it's going to be cold ready go
service
please Alex's food looks amazing but he
seems to be struggling to cope in my
kitchen without his large tea
you got chicken stock boiling over on
the hot plate please okay fine
uh let's go take the [__] pan I want
to wear that [__] off there as well stop
you go you let's go go go go you happy
with that right I'll the yes y go please
let's go table two where's the sauce
good thank you sauce pour the left hand
side Alex I want all the pots and pans
off the floor my kitchen here in 15 I've
never had an accident and today I'm not
going to have one
yeah let's go Jesus Christ very nice
that looks beautiful service please go t
one please yeah thank
[Music]
you the rice is
beautiful you done a fantastic job I'm
I'm still a bit nervous but you know
with with seeing this now I I
feel a lot
better okay Victor yeah four wagu beef
away table one yeah all at the same time
two rice two vegetables and two stunning
wagu beef yes yes thank you come on and
look at me I want you to take a grip
solid hold those rains yeah and get this
thing back on track yes and make sure
every plate is absolutely perfect please
you know your mother sat out there you
know that don't you yes sir yeah
[Music]
okay four beef please stand
by come on nice now nice now let's go
please let's go one thank you thank you
excellent G and just s the nerves and
then know what I need to do you and you
have come back strong and they've got
that Focus going on
[Music]
now plate after plate of Victor's
mouthwatering beef is finally been
served
[Music]
the walk white smells
amazing tast it tastes good the beef is
delicious great
tender what do you think the whole thing
just completely melts in your mouth
doesn't it I'm really proud of my dad
and my brother for just getting this far
and what they've cooked today is being
amazing in a kitchen than not used to as
well our kids definitely done us proud
that's yes
yes
please let's go spot thank you yes thank
you well done St down yes
yes service is over and it's time to
discover what my distinguished guests
think about these two extraordinary
dishes starting with victors
L welome thank you very much this is a
real treat how was the W wonderful it
was so tender and special it worked very
well the W beef how was
that extraordinary like no beef I've
ever tasted before the uh you andu one
had more authentic flavor to me the caou
dish not only the presentation but the
the flavor it's much better as well I
think it was the better dish mainly
because of the tenderness of the beef
the accompanying dishes particularly the
rice the rice was outstanding my Diner's
comments are Testament to the incredible
standards of both Kai and Yu's food but
this competition is about more than just
one dish both these fantastic Chinese
restaurants have had their ups and downs
throughout this heat but now it's time
for me to choose between them winning
today is very important for me uh
because uh I really want to make a proud
uh to my family as a one of uh
top of chin CH in London but if I beat
Ka it' be unbelievable I mean they're
such a fantastic restaurant and their
dish is unbelievable you know so we can
only see you know um if we beat him it
would be
unbelievable only one of them can go
through to the
semi-finals I've got to make a very
difficult
Choice my two top Chinese chefs Alex and
Victor have finished the service of
their lives at my three miching St
restaurant theyve both proved themselves
exceptional competitors but one team has
to go it's time to taste this incredible
food cooked here today starting with a
dish created by Alex from Kai in Mayfair
and the sauce the beef it's been
marinated for 24 hours rice
wine Beast of delicious sauce is very
very strong pumpkins very
crunchy Bamboo
shoe crunchy slightly acidic but
delicious you and you Wago
beef it just melts in your mouth it's
delicious I mean it is really delicious
my God it's got the texture of faga it
needs the greens with it it's very rich
but it's incredibly moish and you feel
like it's done with a a level of
authenticity they both hold an amazing
flavor who has the edge over this
[Music]
one both these teams have cooked their
hearts out but there can only be one
[Music]
winner
okay I brought here today for one reason
and one reason only to do something
extraordinary to do something that
was out of your comfort zone and into a
completely different
League
Kai the dish you looked at it and it was
like it' come out of a a Gucci handbag
it was all precise and just beautifully
done
the
beef phenomenal loved the marinade
intelligent smart and it had that kind
of
wow criticizing the
dish I would have cooked the pumpkin for
another 2 minutes it a little bit
crunchy
inside you and
you the
wagu absolutely beautiful cuz you you
played to your strengths what would I
change it was
simple today I didn't think you'd go
simple I thought you'd go a little bit
more a little bit more
daring but this competition is not going
to be won or lost on one dish alone I'm
looking for the best
restaurant great food great service
great atmosphere friendly approach and
something that you want to go back to
that restaurant for that phenomenal
experience
[Music]
the resturant that's going through to
the
semi-final based on
everything I've seen
tasted and been part of
[Music]
is you and
you
continue those fireworks yeah you
deserve to be out there love the
fireworks love it love it love it good
job you have an amazing restaurant yeah
look after it plus I'm abely GED that
we're not getting through the answer
wasn't the answer we would have liked to
hear but we have to move on and keep
going with with what we do every single
day well done really well done I said
you had a lot of weight on your shoulder
today and you pulled it off and it
wasn't just based on that dish it based
on the whole experience really well done
you should be incredibly proud a bloody
good job really well done okay well done
well done well done I'm very happy it
feels amazing I can't wait to more help
me
more um yeah it's just good can't
[Music]
believe very power yeah all yeah you do
you do a good job a good teacher yeah
you do a good
job
[Music]
very
good good
[Music]
job really sorry to say goodbye to Kai
and that Chef's a bit of a Mad genius
however you and you great restaurant
what an amazing family and they're
they're consistent and
United British restaurants will once a
laughing stock not anymore today we have
some of the most exciting restaurants in
the world together with the best
restaurant team I've chosen the best and
tonight my two favorite restaurants will
be going head-to-head they may be good
but do they have what it takes to go
right to the
[Music]
top for the past 6 months my team and I
have been all over the country checking
out the best of your restaurant
nominations now my Nationwide
competition continues this time to find
the best of
British British restaurants used to be
all about prawn cocktails and black
forest gate but today there are
restaurants all over the UK cooking the
most amazing delicious modern British
food every British restaurant should be
using the finest ingredients we have
some of the best meat fish and
vegetables on the planet so there's no
excuse not to cook with
it you nominated thousands of British
restaurants and along with my best best
restaurant team I've put them under
extreme scrutiny and chosen my two
favorites to do battle for placing the
semi-finals from deepest Kent is a tiny
but elegant Michelin star restaurant the
west house can you get the next two twos
please it's always got to be that same
passion if you like Dy from the first
time you made it they're going
head-to-head with the milestone in
Sheffield put the Water Crest on very
last as it's going it's about Yorkshire
people Yorkshire chefs producing
Yorkshire food we're about to see the
Battle of Britain because the west house
and the Milestone must take on three
extraordinary
challenges the first is every
restaurant's worst nightmare 30 hungry
customers who will arrive and order all
at
once first stop the milestone in
Sheffield I'm actually standing on what
used to be called Pimp's Corner in the
old red light district now this is an
amazing location for a fantastic
restaurant it's run by four local Lads
front of house are the owners Mark and
Matt who' sunk every penny into this
business one salmon one black put on no
idea the kitchen is headed by Young Guns
Simon and James Simon how good cage
fighter no one [__] with you or Serv do
they they these guys are real they're
grafters you can see that just from the
minute you shake their hands it's solid
like a plate of Sheffield
steel I love the fact that they've made
their name by Breaking All the Rules
serving up hearty organic dishes like
rolled pigs head and Trotter sausages
and what's that they're our own uh pigs
that we have it's a farm just outside
Sheffield right r pigs and it goes on
the menu yeah yeah yeah we encourage
customers to actually go out there and
get their hands dirty and start foraging
for us well swap it for beer wine or
meal it's my mom's alotment and she's
picked them all by hand specially for
you guys in just 3 years the M of storm
Sheffield's restaurant scene and the
locals love it there are a great deal
restaurants especially in Sheffield that
are doing food of this quality food is
amazing great environment I'll go for
the ne
noi
nice and it's made on the nettle noi
there's a lot of nettle in there isn't
there yeah the no is delicious PR good
indeed I think what I like more than
anything is the fact that it's very
seasonal very nice I thought that food
was easily of a mission star standard
today you've got a chance to become The
Best of British show off I mean really
show off people used to dealt with it
because of my youth and they did used to
think I were a cocky little [__] but I'm
passionate I'm dedicated and I've got
the drive to take it further
good because my diners are expecting
something incredible and they all need
to be served two courses in Just 2
hours this is a young Dynamic restaurant
that's going places give that experience
to my 30 diners today and they will be
leaving on
Cloud9 any questions don't hesitate to
ask as it's just uh it's just a little
bit
quirky the starters include black
pudding with Bloody Mary cucumber and
gin soup with cured salmon and the Pea
panacotta the P panacotta represents the
first sort of PE to Spring it's a really
nice summary option and the idea is that
you're walking down a Garden
Path rather than choose the more
adventurous options most diners are
sticking to the traditional Fair we got
the homemade black
p
please it looks like we're going to have
a lot of black pudd in on order it's
good that there's such a popular choice
on the menu but the punters might not
want it once they've been served this
first of all from the kitchen today we
have an Amo Boo for you so it's a little
appetizer homemade chicken and black
pudding to me it seems to be a lot of
black pudding coming out of the kitchen
popular today yeah but they're already
starting off with black pudding as well
did not anyone tell them that beforehand
or not no no if they're giving away uh
black pudding as a canop yeah they
should have said it before they took the
orders there's so much black pudding
going out yeah so you go first two
course you black pudding black pudding I
don't eat black pudding twice with Chef
field people they like really heavy
dishes as well they like they like that
meaty flavor that's not a small size of
black pudding is it the man siiz one I
wasn't too keen on the black pudding I
thought it was really nice but was too
much for me to be honest it's on to the
mains Simon's ambitious food includes
turbet poached and red wine nettle noi
and pan fried rabbit loin with pigtail
canoni you want need RAB going stage all
at one in all fairness J all in yeah
yeah Simon has made the unusual decision
to operate this service like a banquet
instead of Staggering the dishes he's
preparing all the main courses at the
same time so it's going to go everything
away the problem now is that Simon has
all the rabbit dishes ready but the
other main cses are lagging behind and
food can't leave the pass until the
order for the whole table is cooked as
it sits in the window and dries out I'm
just getting nervous I don't want a food
coming back saying it's dry you got 1
hour 10 minutes left so if you can just
do one table at a time you'll see a
difference in quality it's not the
fastest restaurant in Britain I'm
looking for the best restaurant not good
enough 2 hours 30 diners two courses
only so stagger them like a normal
service it's it's a shame it's just sat
there disintegrating under those lights
when it should be in front of the
customer and we getting that magic there
and then yes Madam is it possible to f a
little bit otter in fact a lot otter of
course yeah that's these are my worst
fears come true when food sits too long
in the pass it gets cold it gets dry it
gets sent back so that's exactly what I
was trying to say J me it's not a a
banquet everyone's got it in their mind
that we're going to treat this today
like a banquet such a [__] shame the
rabbit L the place not hot the cold
plate can I have another rabbit loin up
now Simon's in trouble there's no rabbit
loin left so Thinking Fast he
substitutes it with rabbit leg but he's
starting from scratch and the leg takes
longer to cook than the loin so it's
short of one portion of rabbit it's
coming up now do you guys want to
explain that to the customer I just you
the rabbit's still raar there that's
what I'm trying to
[Music]
say your vbit oh thank you you're
welcome vbit L this one looks like
they've just thrown it together yeah
it's not even look like rabbit no man
this not cook well enough for me I got
eat my meat like this you want it done a
little bit more for you watch it m done
a little bit more this is
one having tried and failed twice Matt
the owner wants to make amends can I get
your only thing now while only cuz these
guys are eating obviously your
experience has been as been up to
scratch a bit of
fish you okay no problem I'm fine I'll
say when you get guys enjoy it's let
down what was otherwise a great service
it's absolutely delicious really really
good it's a really interesting
combination of textures I'd rate the
service probably 9 out of food is
immense absolutely immense no complaints
whatsoever one little tiny bit of
service just got us Stars fine boo fine
Mains all going fine till that one point
one
[Music]
table
most of the diners leave happy but I've
got
concerns okay uh right how' you feel not
holy happy obious mistakes made um I
think we just got to learn from them
yeah whose decision was it to serve my
diners as a banquet they were mind when
all the checks came on I made a decision
because all of them we're having
starters yeah so I was just going to try
and sweep the room said one course
second course third do that was a big
mistake for me today for every 30
seconds that food is sat there it's
going down and down and down and down in
standard but you got a dream setup
because your customers are SAT 2 m away
from your stove and it was such a shame
cuz then food came back because it
wasn't hot enough the good news is the
customers love the food and that's what
I'm trying to say you're on the verge of
just really popping out there you rear
your own pigs you make your fresh bread
twice a day so you bust your balls to
create that food mood and when it sits
there and they're not benefiting God I
could scream you're doing yourselves an
injustice and that responsibility is on
your shoulder s because you're the head
chef I know and I know you can do a lot
better than what you did
today thank you thank you well
done we're always looking to improve
Lessons Learned yeah we're young
ambitious want to be the best we can
look at what mistakes we did and not
allow them to happen
again next I got Toe to Toe with my
second outstanding restaurant the west
house from Kent there are tables there
watching starts the main courses being
served and yet they haven't another the
order taken you would normally have 30
in the restaurant at once would you so
control free [__]
that it's the British heat of my
Nationwide restaurant competition and a
squad of hungry diners are about to
descend on my second
competitor from thousands of your
nominations I've chosen the west house
from biddington in Kent how how are you
hello nice to see you now good to see
you too right where is he Beav away in
the
kitchen good to see you thank you I met
gra 15 years ago when he worked next
door to my first London restaurant even
then he showed real flare the idea is to
um build dishes around a central
ingredient and you know not fan around
with it too much not Chuck too many
other things on the plate and try and
enhance you know bring out the flavors
Graham hasn't always been a
chef he started out as a drummer for 80s
hair ERS
Yaya no I've never heard of them
either he still has some of the hair but
happily not the shorts luckily I've done
that for a long time various tours and
albums and all sorts and got to see the
world and eat in a lot of restaurants as
well which is quite good 17 years ago
grahe gave up rock and roll to follow
his dream of becoming a chef working in
a string of Top London restaurants then
8 years years ago he took a huge risk he
moved his family to the Kent Countryside
and opened up the west house 18 months
after opening he won his first mission
star that's not bad for a drummer and
when you won the mission star well
you're on your own in the kitchen wow so
it is a onean band back to playing the
drums again everything about this family
restaurant is understated Old English
charm gr's partner Jackie Works front of
house with their children Jake and Jess
who's in charge it would be me happy
being in charge
yeah that means
polite at the beginning I didn't know
what I was doing and uh now 8 years on
it's not as bad as it was but I didn't
like it at first no I'll start off with
the hammmer eggs it's very um very clean
really nice flavors popular on the menu
yeah yeah very I can imagine why what I
like most about West house is the fact
that gra is a is a true Chef he cooks
from the heart not into Frills he's into
flavor and it shows
this quaint English restaurant is about
to be severely tested because my diners
will soon be arriving and ordering all
at the same time my worst fear is it'll
going tears up basically I'm just
expecting the whole family to put in an
amazing performance today to pull this
one off just like the Milestone they
have just 2 hours to serve everyone this
little 11 Table Restaurant is going to
be packed you have a mission star so
myself and my diners are expecting
experience there
[Music]
it's a three and two twos now as soon as
you can get the first table Yeah you
both ready for one no ST one had one
lamb and
one that looks like air traffic control
up there what is that huh I'm getting
there I've never seen tickets written
like that
before 10 [__] what is that there
that's one one ham hog and one mackerel
Jesus Christ the tickets are confusing
but the food coming out of the kitchen
is simply perfect starters include warm
smoked had at kacho with bacon dressing
and peas shoes and that delicious ham HW
with Scotch egg and black
pudding how's the um ham HW in picol
abely fantastic enjoy it really
delicious these are amazing you have the
little Scotch eggs with black ping yeah
so first m c is coming up now Jake
griddle is going to be busy today isn't
it it's going to be a bit in it see a
gly knocking as well it's the first one
for me I've never seen that before just
to calor it off then it gets tossed
through with the AR chokes for me
there's a choice of roast chicken with
herb Noy grill with sfire or Lamb with
sweet breads three of you in here no one
out there I'm
nervous are they all just taken just
left
[Music]
there why would you just dump an order
there like that I'm finding the ordering
system impossible to Fathom and Jackie's
handwriting is more like a doctor's than
a Matra D no one can read it it's one
hat one one he yeah I rewrote the ticket
out and the um then picked that up as
well and you already sent it it was my
fault I left it on there cuz it was but
he couldn't understand my writing so my
fault well today was the [__] day to
do it ever okay table 10 two chicken
what who's table one and five and lamb
two lamb look the two in the middle and
Jackie supposed to be in control of
front of house but it doesn't feel like
it something's not right the service
isn't as I'd imagine for a michion and
start restaurant we've been here about
40 minutes and um aside from the drinks
order we haven't had seen the staff
coming to get take any orders for food
there's five tabls in there they still
haven't had their order taken right he
just shout what orders to get he's
telling you when to take the orders at
the moment yeah get three or get two
three get n and table free yeah you tell
them when to take the orders right
that's right there people that have
already eaten one course I think at
least so hoping that we might get us
what we would like to order soon there
are tables there watching STS make
course is been served and yet they
haven't had the order taken yeah you
would normally have 30 in the restaurant
at once would you so but they haven't
had the order taken let alone just seems
a little
bit alsoo a tit up there the dining room
is controlled by the kitchen so they're
rudderless they can't do anything unless
the kitchen Sayo which is just crazy
they need to
function control freak it's not control
freak it's trying to stay focused and
I'm sorry it is cuz you're not in the
dining room so they're all sat there
staring at your tea the ding room so
control freak all right I've never SE
anything so stupid in all my life chefs
don't tell waiters when to take an order
that's the responsibility of the dining
room to give it to the chef he's trying
to control [__]
everything does Ben know how to do main
courses as well uh no not yet not yet
eight months in this kitchen working
alongside you and he can't do a main
course yet I think CU you don't want to
tell them it you know that no it's time
you know there's a lot to do over there
sorry about the delay for the starters
just over an hour how are they lovely
it's really very nice very waited far
too long um drinks we ordered some
drinks before they took our order and we
haven't had them drinks and um even
before we started taking an order
nothing's hit the table
yet drinks on through hours
ago water they're not lying let's put it
that way but they just say theyve
ordered drinks and nothing's happen
sorry [__] hell to give R back to the
front of house I can see a solution if
you'd like it different I can go and get
that cooked further for you can you
place everything on it because
everything's cold now okay right yeah
Graham's son Jake is on top of things
just be a few minutes just redoing it
for you okay y I will do wouldn't you be
best running a day you seem to be the
only one that actually knows how to do
it properly that's not been disparaging
to M but you seem to know what you're
doing it sort of I wanted to do it mine
and his way and she's got her little
ways but you seem to beak out you seem
to know and this service would be a lot
smoother if I had somebody running
it it was tough it was tough could you T
the food was absolutely delicious I
think the only thing that wasn't really
up to standard was the uh the service it
was worth a wait though that's that's
the good
thing oh [__]
that my diners have no complaints about
the food because the cooking is
inspiring but grahe is tripping up the
service and he has to understand
this okay here's the
issue
unfortunately okay the service is
nowhere near to the standard of food you
left two tables you know sat there for
over an hour before we even took their
order and the dining room felt short
staffed food sent to the same table
twice the Stars already gone Jackie
across the two hours you didn't give me
the impression that you were enjoying
enjoying it as much as you should have
are you 100% happy running that dying
room on a normal day yeah on a normal
day but today I was a bit you know
panicking yeah Jake you were the one
Shining Light out there and why you're
not at the helm relieving the pressure
from your mother and working closely
with your father I never know you've
sort of castrated the dying room because
you're controlling them you've got to
cut
some of the control freak in you and
allow them to do their job and you'll be
surprised at the results I'm telling you
it cuz I want this place to really
succeed in this competition why cuz the
food is beautiful well
done it's like any any criticism you you
take it on board you filter it through
and uh and react so yeah I mean there's
some there's some food for
full I'm looking for the best restaurant
not the best chef and service is crucial
today customers are prepared to wait but
they're not prepared to wait for an hour
to get their order taken no
[Music]
chance by pushing both restaurants to
extremes I've uncovered the areas they
need to improve on now I've invited them
both to London for a progress report but
the restaurants haven't got a clue that
they face one more test without telling
them I sent in my secret diners because
I really want to find out exactly what
happens when the teams don't know
they're under
scrutiny I've sent in top food critic
Simon Davis with instructions to be as
difficult as possible something that
comes quite naturally to him the teams
don't know that I've been spying on them
first to face of music is the
Milestone I wanted to make sure that you
weren't just rolling out the red carpet
for me I had a secret Diner in there and
this is what he
saw we grab some lunch do we just grab a
seat you just grab a seat okay great I
love that I love the fact you do
dripping ready to start actually such a
good idea the dripping you'd have your
your roast and then the dripping you'd
have throughout the week spread on the
bread oh so good so
good cheap cheerful slightly nostalgic
really nice and look how happy
you know customer sound really good all
right this is Ox tongue corn
beef no way no seasoned or not very
Bland that's quite disappointing
actually it's such a shame cuz the diner
shot up wow dripping ex and then back a
[__] when you've got the balls to put
corn beef and oxun on a plate that
simply it has to be seasoned perfectly
we actually changed that already because
we read the comment card that night just
lack of seasoning it was essentially a
lack of seasoning yeah
yeah you know thanks a
lot oh really well I wasn't expecting
that I know I'm perf to pay I'd like to
pay for it I'd like to pay for
it I know that's what
you really they won't let us pay no
charge nice gesture gives them no reason
to complain about it I love the way he
was so patient and so polite really
polite on several occasions we've seen
some
really succinct um very focused ability
in the kitchen with very well sourced
food and then you get things like these
this B of
chips you
know pubs not even places that claim
call themselves gastro pubs that serve
better chips in that it's
useless burn chips it's a simple stupid
mistake that shouldn't really happen
ever can I have a word there a chef
there a chef chef
around well no I want to talk to him
about something I want to talk to him
about that look at that would you eat
that would you eat that person no so why
should I eat
it no I want to talk to
Chef bu me two
more how about the dessert menu yeah i'
love to see all right hi they're
brilliant well they're gone now but I
wanted to talk you I've noticed them
what is like two or three trains
upstairs I'm trying to teach right how
to come sometimes issues with especially
when out so we do understand there is
issues
with especially
Che we but I just wonder why you allow
that ship to go out when it was burned I
wasn't in
[Music]
there back in and back out sounds like
you're trying to do quite a lot up there
have a l to what I mean so I understand
There's issues well you better get back
up there but thanks for coming down all
right
bye I thought you were going to blow a
gasket to be honest I could cry I could
cry a chip goes out like it's on the
back of an ass end of a a a takeaway van
there's flashes of Brilliance in there
and it works in such a magical way and
yet you bust your balls fresh bread
rearing pigs cooking school you know
slow down and focus what you've
got the chips were burned they shouldn't
have been burned they should have been
absolutely fine they should have been
fantastic the guy should have been
picking them out of the ball saying my
God these are [__] amazing chips we
seen a lot of problems that we do need
to solve but we've also seen a lot of
strengths that we know we have got so as
long as we bring everything together
tighten it up I think we can improve and
we can make things better than they ever
have
been next they're not busy how could you
confuse te table my secret Diner snoops
at the west house here it's about that
level of perfection on every plate and
both teams come head-to-head for the
final battle [__] how can you forget
that lce I'm [__] up come on one more
table let's
go the Milestone from Sheffield are
battling out with the west house from
Kent to become my best British
restaurant grahe and his family team
from the west house are about to
discover that I've been spying on
them I sent in undercover Diner Sarah
deran Robinson she's a cookie writer and
a food
consultant when I sent my 30 diners into
the west house Mom Jackie confused
everyone with her ordering system have
things improved since unknown to all
four of you you've actually been under
two tests cuz after I left I sent in a
secret Diner oh and here's what they saw
do you make the bread here yeah all the
bread's made every morning comes down at
8: clock usually who the shf my dad side
oh God he makes bread smells delicious
it is I do like bread especially the
brown one I really like the brownen that
one he seems quite proud of his father
and what they do because he talks about
him with great affection I kind of feel
like I'm sitting in the family
kitchen it's made it all a lot more
personal actually really good lovely
start oh no now what is this again what
I
guine I I think I ordered a mackerel CES
excuse me
excuse oh that's okay I thought i' got
mad for a
second
[Music]
okay they're not busy how could you
confuse the two
tables should remember what's going
on damn watching your food being put
down on a table in front of you it's
like eating secondhand food whenever
that happens again food goes back into
the kitchen I forgot that how'd you feel
watching that bit gutted that I messed
it up so I could go and write those
tickets for you now and show you the
correct procedure and what ways could be
so much easier for you well do me a
favor do that cuz I've been trying to do
that for about 8 years but I get ignored
maybe she'll listen to you
yeah so I ordered the um the interesting
thing is they didn't ask me how I wanted
the lamb done so I'm afraid when it
arrives I may discover I've got a
problem with
it ah thank you I'm sorry to be pain I
didn't realize that the lamb came so
pink would it be possible to have one
better done yeah I'll just go see thank
you surely you must ask a customer
medium pink well
done no that's their probative it's not
this old 1980s Chef mentality what I say
goes and it saves the frustration
doesn't it it saves that dish been done
twice oh thank
you L and the chicken I'll just be right
back with goodness mushroom so they'
brought two completely new main courses
rather than bringing back the half C
first plate that P back an entirely new
main
course that is very impressive great
recovery wonderful recovery the fact
that you took time and done two new main
courses you have pain in the ass of the
kitchen but you did it without without
any hassle and left a really nice
impression despite the fact that they
actually ended up cooking four Mo
courses they've only charged for one
each so it's £48 ahead food is just bous
that is outstanding value for money it
really clearly experience phenomenal
food delicious value for money spot on I
want to come back here cuz it felt like
they were com to your house if you get
up to the speed with a modernday system
of taking tickets it doesn't need to be
that pressurized putting those dishes
down so we have to look at the
disorganization that's
it you know I came straight back in the
kitchen and told Grand what I'd done I I
remember that and I was so gutted that
I'd done it you know cuz as I said in
years I've never made that mistake
before it would be fantastic to sit
there see that secret footage and
there'd be absolutely not a single thing
wrong sit there and Pat each other on
the back and we leave but life's not
really like that is it grae's putting a
brave face on things but he must realize
he's got a lot of work to do if he's
going to win this
competition I put both teams through the
ringer to test their skills as chefs and
restaurant now it's their last chance to
prove
themselves
to earn a place in the semi-finals
they've got to cook one exceptional dish
something worthy of a place on my three
Missin Star
menu I'd be a liar if I should I slept
well last night cuz you're just running
everything through over and over and
over in your head it's just all the
pre-match nerves and it there so
pre-match
tension quite daunting never been in a
place quite like
this it's a mixture of excitement and
nerves I want to win more than anything
got to get everything absolutely right
so it all rides on this really good luck
to earn the honor of representing
British cuisine in the semifinals their
dish must be nothing less than
exceptional this is the Battle of
Britain and for me two of the best
restaurants are going head-to-head for
the very first time there's no
undercover footage there's no coach it's
just you on a plate it's 20 stunning
dishes and that is it make sure it is
you going through to the semi-final good
luck I've asked them to create their
dishes using a classic British
ingredient
benison these are two amazing
restaurants coming head to-head and for
me the best of britishes always excites
nor than any other category I'm
expecting great flavors great balance
and phenomenal
fireworks I've invited 20 estam guests
to judge both team's Creations the
diners include Elizabeth Carter editor
of the good food guide and award-winning
British farmer Wilfred Emanuel Jones and
the front of house teams from both
restaurants are here too so in terms of
nervous and skeleton turn what are you
11 11 this is our last chance to prove
ourselves I order four cover table to
West house for venison
loin grahames divides the dish worthy of
his Michelin star
status he's using venison loin served
with onion marmalade potatoes pickled
cherries and finished with crispy bacon
and venison liver it's hard to get
because the H breakfast they call it
they tend think this part it's got a
great flavor you know but you need to
keep it nice and pink nice and
rare it's a technical dish with a
potential for disaster especially if
graes control Freer prevents suev Ben
from supporting him I know what you like
you won't let anyone do anything what
are you actually doing today apart from
making gra tea are you actually
participating in the cooking yeah
definitely I'm doing all the garnish
looking after the and bacon potatoes
onion marmalade cherries and I'll help
plate as well if you let me I know you
love taking your time when you put these
dishes together it's actually 1 hour for
20 not 1 hour per dish just in case cuz
I know what you like when you get buried
away there's no pulling you back out
there is there my f of GRA is that the
food is so complex there's four or five
elements so he just needs offload and
open up and bring Ben with him to get
that dish absolutely perfect so for more
venison loine away now gr please West
house on table two please Ben send one
table clear your [__] down send the next
table clear your [__] down yeah what I
do Ben I'm going to leave these for you
to play up like the last while I cut the
LI
it graes delegating at last but with
time on his hands he started cooking the
delicate venison liver too early that
liver is your is your danger zone you
know that grae I do danger zone how do
you want to serve it I want to serve it
rare R so you cook it rare here it goes
out there pink when it sits there it's
firm as [__] you understand so when he's
2/3 of the plate dressed and you're
happy have the confidence just to fry
that at the last
moment tell me when I'm going to liver
yeah yep you ready uh yeah go for it so
Liv in yeah
yeah try and stand those Cherry stems up
please they look fantastic absolutely
fantastic no two ways About It Go please
table two two more ven way now please
grae with Chef table four please thank
you working well as a team at the moment
I mean it's great expend getting invol
with stuff on the past allowing me to
cook the liver and fin last minute
Graham's happy with his food but will
the diners
agree it smells absolutely superb smells
really
lovely flavors are all there I mean
exactly what we always get in the
restaurant I'm very proud of him there
it's a good dish it looks good as well
both are good to nail
it Graham's dish has set the bar
seriously High to be with a chance of
winning the Milestone Lads really have a
battle on their hands so on order four
covers Table Six milestone for venison
Wellington yes sir thank you big
competition today going head-to-head
against the mission Star Restaurant you
got no cooking school today no
downstairs no upstairs one kitchen 20
diners no excuses what's the chances I'm
optimistic um yeah I think we're going
to do it obviously they've got a
Michelin star we haven't so sort of The
Underdogs but if we can do this then it'
be
amazing head jef Simon is pulling out
all the stops with a busy dish of rast
venison loin and a haunch of Venison and
nettle Wellington served with beetroot
fondant Water Crest puree and bra
lettuce this could be the dish of my
career if all goes well then it could
change things for us drastically how far
you off Simon 6 minutes seven six yeah
six s
minutes Simon's dish requires perfect
timing something he messed up when he
fed my coach
[Music]
diners in the
midle I'd rather get the customers
waiting extra 5 minutes yeah serve a
beetroot that's not cooked properly here
there's no room for mistakes all six
elements of this dish must be cooked to
Perfection I four ven up to the pass
now guys make every plate count
yeah good happy service yep go please
but in his haste to get the food out
Simon has made a terrible school boy
error
what
oh [__] how you forget that lettuce I'm
[__] up JY come on you should know
that by now get me Rob please urgently
let's go uh that's the bra's lettuce
that we've got off the main C is fine
it's not on there now they haven't
finished it not even halfway through go
please yeah yeah just apologize quickly
thank you
[__] following just behind is a bra
baby gem
lettuce a more experienced Chef would
recovered from a mistake like this
quickly but Simon's rattled I missed it
off the blade and so I'm pissed off I'm
pissed off yourself look at me look at
me then it's gone yeah you can pull it
back come on one more table let's go
Chef thank you yes chef 30 seconds V
will be first right coming up on this
yeah yeah up lights up
up now this time the letter is is on the
plate yeah not separate t one please
yeah see this start waking up another
Forge yeah yeah s's bounced back and
need's talking to James and more
importantly they're together as a team
so it's a dynamic duo as opposed to one
up one down
happy with that yeah sa this very nice
the dishes look fantastic absolutely
delicious James yeah Sim keep it going
yeah yeah that's your last table yes
make that last table look exactly and
taste exactly the same as the first
pleas chatney okay good off you
go a roasted loin venison with net
Wellington it looks absolutely brilliant
it smells divid much make this is just
spectacular incredibly succulent clean
flavors beet really good yeah hold on
guys yeah yeah big deep breath oh on
shift nice
one service is over my Discerning guests
have tasted both restaurant's food I
want to find out what they thought
starting with a milestone let's talk to
venison with the Wellington wonderful
combination of flavors the texture the
taste it really worked for me wolfred
how was it the person who did the
Wellington I would he is so eager to win
yeah he looks like a cage fighter like
he's ready for action big way and you
could see that in the dish there was too
much going on and then the one we Chang
was a bit more laidback is the west
house that was my preference and and
it's because it wasn't trying too hard I
preferred the west house and I thought
the way they cook the venison was
perfect and I absolutely love the liver
which is something I normally don't eat
and was a real treat I preferred the
Wellington actually yeah I thought it's
actually fantastic I thought the PTI was
brilliant it was really light extremely
difficult to choose yes bit like two
beautiful ladies who you
choose both brigades have performed well
but they've also come up against
pressure G doesn't miss anything does he
he just eyes on everything I think
overall it went really really well yeah
the food looks amazing we tasted every
dish that went out so hopefully that'll
be the winning dish I'm hoping for the
best but it's all in the eyes of gon at
the end of there both of these
resturants have great strengths but
they've also both got
flaws I'd love to put them both through
to the semi-finals but I can't which of
them has the potential to be truly great
I've got to
[Music]
decide my top two British restaurants
the Michigan starred West house from
Kent and the Milestone from Sheffield
have absolutely cooked their hearts
out I'm about to tell one of them their
competition Journey ends
here there have been errors yet both
still produce truly outstanding
food to help me make my choice I need to
compare both
dishes both dishes visually stunning I
can transport these two plates and put
them in any top restaurant and they
wouldn't look out of place that's how
excited I am about the best of British
Milestone braze lettuce beetroot a
Wellington done with the cheap
cup phenomenal and the nettle pancake
mind-blowing it's delicious buttery
slightly gy loin of venison that just
just melts in your mouth it's just like
put a knife through butter it's that
soft
Wonderful West house got that W
Factor m
delicious God so hard liver very
difficult to get right it's got that
little touch of gamey bitterness to it
that really goes well with the rich cup
from the loin seasoned beautifully the
cherries make it work because of the
acidity and it's got that side of that
Moorish Sumptuous richness I am really
taken back by these dishes the standard
is incredible I love this one love it
love it love it but then there's magic
in this one for me right
now they're both
[Music]
winners two remarkable British
restaurants but only one can win a place
in the
semi-finals okay
um I invited both of you here today to
blow me away for one restaurant to excel
um I didn't get
that no because I got both restaurants
excelling in a big way and
it's amazing to
see that kind of performance in what my
mind is one of the most exciting
categories but the joy of watching and
tasting what you've just done in there
has now become a nightmare on a person
person FR because I have to eliminate
one of you and put one of you through to
the semi-final so I thought well which
dish would I put on my lunch menu
tomorrow morning I came up with the
decision both of the dishes would sit
there that's what I'm faced with right
now so the
winner is not based on one dish because
if it
was both of you would be going through
think of the journey
I turn up with a coach 30 diners come
swooping in causes havoc and it's the
biggest pain in the ass that any
restaurant could ever wish for I then
film you undercover I send in an awkward
secret Diner to turn the place upside
down to see how you handle that kind of
pressure here's my
question which restaurant would I prefer
to return to West us would I go to that
intimate stunning family run Michelin
star done with
charm or would it be the Sheffield I
suppose balls of steel because it is run
with a heartbeat that is missing in a
lot of restaurants
tough very
tough it is so hard you've got no
idea the restaurant going through to the
semi-final based on everything I've
seen
[Music]
is milone
congratulations that was for me one of
the toughest most difficult decisions
I've ever made but that dish was unique
and don't stop cooking like that
yeah going out this stage as far as I'm
concerned makes us you know at worst the
second best British restaurant in the
competition so you know we we carry on
we do we do what we do at the restaurant
and you know keep the customers happy
and that's that's the main
thing tell me something better uh guys
well done really well done yeah
phenomenal you pulled out the subs there
today and it worked yeah good job well
done well done we
done
cheers
it's just amazing it's fantastic it's a
dream come true it's proved a point to
us for and to a lot of other people that
are expecting a lot from us and thank
God we've actually come through and
we've we' we've made it with that kind
of determination that's where the future
of British cooking is up there in
Sheffield but right now this competition
is only going to get tougher and I hope
they don't let me
down